Speaker 1: All right. This is this is sad news.
Our good friend who has filled in for me before,
Jesse Dallimore, announced
yesterday that he sadly has cancer
and he has a whole video message about it to his
audience. And he explains that he went in for and
this is there's a Twitter thread that you can look
at. He went in for a colonoscopy late last week.
And yesterday he was told that he has
colon cancer and there is a mass and it is
adenocarcinoma does not yet know the stage or the
prognosis, but believes that it's not stage four,
meaning it hasn't spread to other organs. Jesse
is going to need surgery. He is going to then
learn is it stage one or two, in which case that's
hopefully the end of the journey. Or as he writes,
if it's three, then he would start chemo. There's
a lot of uncertainty and we are all pulling for
Jesse as as I tweeted to him yesterday, I was just
on a call with Jesse because we were working on
some stuff. And Jesse has super graciously
filled in for me in the past last summer,
and he's just a really nice guy. The thing about
Jesse is that I'm the nice guy that you see in
his clips is really Jesse. And it's horrible news.
And I know that lots of our other friends in the
progressive media community are rallying around
Jesse. There's no ask here right now. I'm just
telling you all about something in the community
that's going on. That's that's horrible. So
feel free to. Send Jesse a tweet. We're, of
course, wishing him the best. Or, you know, you
can leave positive vibes over on the video clip
that he did about this or really just whatever.
But we send Jesse our best really sad news,
and we hope to have good news from Jesse about
treatment and prognosis sooner than later. All
right, Jesse, everybody here is pulling for you